firstly charles always great to be back
on your show thank you so much regarding
those headlines just ignore them i stand
by my statement look at this stage the
bitcoin network is too big to ban we
currently have more than tens of
thousands of miners securing the network
globally in different countries on
different continents and in different
jurisdictions this is really important
that they are in different jurisdictions
because despite what the usa decides to
do doesn't mean that will happen in
other parts of the world latin america
is an amazing example el salvador
adopting bitcoin as legal tender and
it's having domino effects on the rest
of latin america panama are introducing
similar bills we even saw um not just
latin america but now in the middle east
in europe we're seeing similar things
happening with the president of el
salvador actually going to turkey um and
meeting with the president of turkey and
they're talking supposedly about bitcoin
so as i always say and i mean no
disrespect america isn't the center of
the world there are other jurisdictions
that are going to take more progressive
and friendlier approaches less than a
minute to go there in my ear two things
a how much of this fed potential
quantitative tightening uh is playing a
role here cutting off the spigots and
are you buying the dip
so i don't really think that's the key
issue here the quantity of easing the
key issue is the current geopolitical
situation we're living through right now
we're seeing an impending war going on
um in russia the uk and the usa
politically are very much involved
that's going to cause a lot of concern
people are obviously going to be selling
their riskiest assets there's some
confusion regarding covid nobody really
knows what's happening some countries
are um lifting rules some aren't so
there's a lot of uncertainty fear
uncertainty a doubt people are going to
be selling their riskiest assets and am
i buying the dip of course i'm buying
the dip but charles like i always say i
get paid in bitcoin so i'm always
technically buying the dip are you
buying the dip
you know i set up the account i got 90
grand in there i set it up on november
9th at the high so i'm real close that's
why i'm asking i'm real close you'll be
the second person to know once i do get
ready i'll tweet you
let me know thank you so much for having
me always appreciate it